Millions here are on the move
a mass migration from cities to home
towns
in Beijing stations some came Laden with
presents others with excessive
precaution a covert surge is the context
here
is definitely a sense here that people
are wanting to travel wanting to go and
see family that they perhaps haven't
seen for a very long time but it's not
quite as busy as you might expect a
sense perhaps that covert is still Rife
here
but for those who've recovered reunions
are relished strict zero covered rules
meant families like Lunas haven't seen
each other for a year I think that there
will be a big chance to to spread but I
think it's better to think the family is
more important that you know getting
whatever to be sick again and you think
that's how a lot of Chinese people feel
yeah yeah because it's been when you're
three years it's really a long time we
want to left our left to get normal
again
we joined her and others on the train to
shangdong a province with the largest
number of elderly people officials say
80 percent of this country have already
been infected the fear is further spread
on the train we meet Mr Wong he hasn't
seen his family for three years I ask if
he's worried
activity
a little he says there'll be so many
people flowing out
on the line small rural places with
small rudimentary facilities this tiny
Clinic is the only resource in town but
the doctor here says she's not worried
[Music]
but places like this have suffered on
the eve of New Year under a blanket of
fireworks people burn paper money to
honor the devs there are more to
remember this year over 12 000 just last
week it's unclear how many in total
families like the yins it's just a joy
to be able to gather The Young and the
old together preparing traditional foods
the grandchildren receiving money as
gifts
over dinner the head of the family says
he thinks the worst is behind them
it's unclear if this week will spark
something bigger even president XI says
he's worried about further rural spread
but for now for many this mainly feels
like a longed for release Helena Smith
Sky News in shangdong